everyone says that I met and they asked
me that question what draws me to the
ice and what amazes me is how many
people follow high in the mountains of
southern Africa there are 15 fearless
swimmers competing in one of the most
extreme races on earth with no wetsuits
no protection they must swim a single
kilometre in water cold enough to kill
them they call it a race but most would
call it insanity has found a ROM mark I
will tell you the members of the
International Ice Swimming Association
don't just battle to the finish they're
fighting to stay alive
swimming cold water has become my
passion okay we need another task force
but this one's it the ice was the icing
on the cake
I find the ice extreme I'm attracted to
extreme challenges no doubt swimming in
ice is a dangerous sport
it's not adrenaline junkie polar bear
type of experience he actually had to
swim one kilometer extremely fast in
water of under five degrees in just
speedo goggles and a cap these are the
rules I founded the International Ice
swimming Association I'd love it to
become a proper international recognised
sport the double hit physiologically
it's a nice firm which is challenging
and your altitude
most of you have not been an altitude
before we mean Africa in the mountain of
Lesotho when you found ice and we have
in the national south african ice
championship no way in southern africa
you're going to find water five degrees
or below it to here last year we had
about 13 national championship like this
we have now swimmers in 28 countries
around the world we are doing a ice swim
in africa which is a bit ridiculous if
you ask anyone we also think it's
ridiculous it's a massive mental
challenge to get in that water and to
perform physically for an extended
period of time you keep going takes a
lot of manpower and that's what I love I
love pushing the boundaries and in these
conditions
it's not a sport where you have to be
Lin mean and beautiful to win
you have to have around 20% body fit you
have to be fit you have to Train so your
body and your mind know how to deal with
the shock
panic is the number one killer
initially you can't tell if the water is
very hot or very cold
it's almost burns the first three
minutes is painful and then you sort of
settle in and everything goes numb their
body temperature starts to drop getting
into this water poses the hazard of
hypothermia to the athlete it causes
havoc in your budget to blood pressure
to your heart rate to your oxygen to
your brain there's only one thing that
goes through your mind breathe the ice
takes a breath away and if you don't
control it you can get into the world of
trouble
the average time in the water is 15 to
20 minutes which is still safe it's a
hugely mental sport for me it's mind
over matter it's not you racing against
someone else it's about you against the
ice and the cold and basically competing
against your own mind this cold starts
to affect the function of the nervous
system and so confusion delirium
sometimes happens the athletes can start
to hallucinate or they can have amnesia
if you feel dizzy and disorientated you
should get out it's such a hard decision
to make you know you're so close to
finish
as you come out of the water the brain
starts releasing blood from the core
that process is what we call the after
drop in ten minutes and suddenly a core
body temperature can drop from 34 to 30
and that causes a havoc if you if you
haven't been there it's a scary
experience
come my legs
the proper ICU doctors and recovery unit
to make sure that no one goes over the
edge
it's literally like going up to
rollercoaster you know that feeling
slowly slowly slowly and suddenly you
get there when you get there and see
people eyes go like you call it The
Devil's look they know everything what's
going on they you everything you just
can't respond you are you know like a
massive sort of tunnel vision focused on
hanging in there for the lifetime back
into me I don't know if that's a good
thing because it's all gone I'm sorry to
turn the corner so I'm feeling better
but right now one of them after the dust
is settled you feel like a champion
before they start swimming everyone
asked himself why am I doing this
what am I trying to prove to myself guys
well done to all of you I know it wasn't
easy and I know that not everyone
finished I think it's part of the
process
then after I finish I can't wait for the
next adventure and I'm high for days my
big dream is to get it to the Winter
Olympic Games as a sport will be my
legacy the beauty of what we're doing
here today is to show that if there is a
wheeled ease away